superheroes are mass culture the comic
books are niche tens of millions of
people saw Captain America Civil War but
this past May Marvel only sold a hundred
seventy seven thousand copies of Civil
War two but if you took Marvel's opening
credits and replace this with this even
the people who'd never touched a comic
book page would notice everybody knows
the comic book font
how could there be a universally
recognized font for something that for a
half-century was written by hand
is it a font at all how is that possible
these fonts are made by people called
letterers and their work shows how
hundreds of lettering artists can come
together into a single recognizable
style and how we as consumers then
managed to get it completely wrong
[Music]
if you go to a comic book store you can
see comics that were gloriously lettered
by hand like this 1964 issue of Thor yes
it was a Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
production and they worked with Artie
semuc Artie probably gave Thor this epic
room letterers place and draw expressive
dialogue bubbles like this one but in
Artie's day they also hand wrote every
word in a dialogue bubble in a lot of
practical conditions shaped the artistry
of the letters what I think of as
comic-book lettering is 1960s Marvel
Comics they were mainly lettered by two
guys Artie Simic and Sam Rosen for me
they had a nail that's John Rochelle who
founded comic crafts a comic book font
company with Richard Starkey they're
letterers and writers and they make
fonts like this one and comics like this
one the fonts a design imitate a style
that formed out of necessity that style
came out of the newspaper world in
newspaper technology early comics like
Little Nemo which came out in the 1900s
started to develop a style that was
readable on cheap paper you can see it
forming in this bubble it's all caps
like a comic book font but it's somehow
wrong as time went on that changed yeah
I think certainly early on comic strips
and comic books were lettered by the
artist and then as they gained
popularity that's when the production
model started to get split up just
basically to meet the demand a letter
room was probably just somebody in the
office with good handwriting okay it
could do it fast enough but the forms
limitations shape the style that emerged
across the industry most letterers used
in Ames guide like this one to create
their lines which meant each letter hit
the same height and more likely hit
middle in the middle of the line these
letters became kind of squad because
they're really trying to hit the lines
on the top and bottom of the guide that
led to generally rounder O's and fatter
A's with lower crosses earlier letterers
also used a speedball mid pen
or a technical pet these things here
their nibs they determine the shape of a
stroke and an artist could use any type
of nib they wanted but a lot of the time
they chose names that gave them a
consistent stroke width compare this
low-key to one that shows up in Times
New Roman now look at the times when
they it has a skinny base on the L a
very narrow o at the top and all sorts
of other little details where the stroke
width varies RT simek's loci however has
a really consistent width to it the
quality of the pages also influence the
style that letterers chose here's that
1964 Thor next to Thor from 2016 just
look at the difference between the pages
today's glossy Thor can handle all sorts
of letters but 1964's
couldn't letterers wrote in all caps to
compensate look at this ad from 1964
store the ink is blotchy and hard to
read all caps helps fix that and see how
the tail on the Y and G forces the whole
line to be longer all caps helped
letterers fit more dialogue into less
space and keep it clear on lousy paper
other rules emerged to never cross an
eye unless it's by itself always
italicize in bold for emphasis and all
of them were made to make comics printed
on bad paper easier to read consistency
also mattered in case another letter er
jumped in to finish a page or fix up a
typo and all those constraints and
choices created the handwritten style
that we recognized but today to call it
handwriting would be lying Richard
Starkey n--'s who runs comic craft with
John Rachelle was frustrated with the
work involved in lettering this is The
Killing Joke
it's a classic controversial 80s comic
that's been reprinted in deluxe editions
and Richard Starkey --nz lettered a star
Keynes had an experienced letterers
appreciation of detail but he was so
frustrated by the work involved and in
industry that new to computers were the
future but wasn't willing to go there
just yet
been earlier attempts to standardize
fonts in comics most famously a
publisher called EC Comics used a guide
to trace every letter and the result
ended up looking kind of mechanical like
type other publishers played with type 2
but Star Kings and Rochelle led the
charge into digital fonts for a long
time we had things our way there were a
lot of technophobes
in comics so a lot of people who didn't
want to change those people have grown
old and there are people in their
twenties editing and designing comics
now and they expect you to have every
font in our library and then some today
companies like comic crafts and
competitors like blame bots make fonts
that letterers can download and then
work with in programs like Adobe
Illustrator they still make the bubbles
and design the text they just don't use
ink to do it but those companies don't
just sell one comic book font they sell
a ton and that's because the idea of a
comic book font is a mistake in the
first place the general public only
really became aware of fonts with the
rise of personal computers this chart
shows the appearances of the word font
in books from 1960 to 2000 we can see
how vet Iike an Arial and future because
our computers has trained us to look for
them some fonts came with our machines
or condensed in the document cloud we
notice them we see these tiny
differences there have always been
hundreds of comic book fonts to attuned
to the idiosyncrasies of the artists who
used to letter them but most people just
like me haven't been trained to see the
nuance in their work comics fans and
letterers do that's a talk line are
different letters have their letters of
the alphabet that are another signature
Dave Gibbons his deans Jimmy his G is
almost a six it's a real loop around on
itself even Richard Starkey has a quirk
a jagged hook on his s that always
stands out as technology allows for
variety and
of use creativity continues to flourish
even if handwriting gets digitized
comics like Klaus can use color with
abandon and artsy comics like the
joiners are able to experiment with all
kinds of fonts without worrying about
cheap paper reducing readability the
comic-book font is a starting point an
idea we keep around because it shows the
Verve of comics within that style is the
variety of different artists and
designers expressing a key element in
every story and maybe even some of those
superhero movie fans will notice it so
in addition to identifying a letter or
by their handwriting sometimes you can
spot one by the style of their bubbles
John workman is famous for creating word
bubbles that jut right into the gutter
of a page and it creates a really
distinctive style that's easy to spot